ahora vamos a averiguar cuánto tiene que
pagar de impuestos una persona soltera
que gana 50 mil dólares al año de
impuestos estatales suponiendo que esta
persona vive en una ciudad o un estado
que tiene impuestos locales y aquí tengo
los tabuladores que corresponden a este
estado donde vive esta persona cada
estado puede tener diferentes
tabuladores de impuestos y estos también
cambian año con año pero lo importante
aquí es ver cómo es que se calculan
estos impuestos en el estado en el que
yo me encuentro
tengo una deducción estándar que se
encuentra aquí de tres mil 769 dólares
para una persona soltera y aquí en lugar
de tener una exención personal que va a
reducir el ingreso personal al que se le
pueden aplicar impuestos como lo vimos a
nivel federal aquí se tiene un crédito
de impuestos que esencialmente es un
crédito sobre nuestros impuestos esto no
reduce el ingreso al que se puede
aplicar impuestos eso se usa
directamente sobre los impuestos que uno
tiene que pagar ahora veamos cuál es el
ingreso al que se le aplica impuestos en
mi estado
con 50 mil dólares que es mi ingreso
bruto y después tengo una deducción
estándar en mi estado de 3.769 y esto me
da un ingreso al que se le pueden
aplicar impuestos de 46 mil 231 ahora si
vemos estos tabuladores pareciera que
caemos en el tabulador que corresponde
al 8% pero como lo vimos en los
impuestos federales no es que este 8% se
aplique a todo el total del ingreso que
acabamos de calcular solo pagamos el 8%
sobre el incremento que está por encima
de 37 mil 5 dólares para el resto de los
tabuladores pagamos un 1% en los
primeros 7 mil 124 dólares
pagamos 2% en el incremento que va de 7
mil 124 a 16 1980 y así continuamos con
los demás tabuladores vamos a calcular
todo esto así que vamos a pagar un 1%
por los primeros 7 mil 124 dólares
a esto le agregamos el 2% que vamos a
pagar de la diferencia entre 16 1980
- 7.124
y cerramos paréntesis a eso le agregamos
el 4% que se paga de la diferencia entre
26 mil 657 menos
16 1890
pasamos al siguiente tabulador
voy a pagar el 6%
por lo que se encuentre como diferencia
entre 37.000 5 - 26.657
ya casi llegamos al final
voy a pagar el 8% de aquello que esté
por encima de los 37 mil cinco dólares
vamos a ver cuál es esa diferencia mi
ingreso al que se le aplica en impuestos
es de 46 mil 231
y a esto le quito el límite inferior de
este tabulador 37.000 5
y esto nos da vamos a revisar que
hayamos escrito correctamente todas las
cantidades okay parece que todo está
bien vamos a ir con calma
revisando paso por paso que hayamos
escrito bien todas las cantidades
redoble de tambores por favor el
resultado es 2018 dólares y esto es sólo
basado con lo que tenemos en los
tabuladores aquí así que escribimos a
nivel estatal
tenemos que pagar 2 mil 18 dólares de
impuestos al menos en este tabulador
pero ahora tenemos que tomar en cuenta
este crédito al impuesto y esto a
diferencia de la deducción o la exención
que esto es lo que hacen es reducir mi
ingreso al que se le aplican impuestos
el crédito al impuesto lo que hace es
afectar directamente este impuesto
estatal así que de lo que tengo aquí de
los 2 mil 18 dólares le restó el crédito
del impuesto que es 102
y esto nos da como resultado mil 916
dólares
y estos son mis impuestos estatales aquí
ya habíamos visto de nuestros impuestos
federales 9.754 y ahora encontramos 1916
a nivel estatal así que el sueldo que
nos va a quedar para llevar a casa es
50.000 nuestro ingreso bruto original le
restamos el impuesto federal 9.754 que
bueno de hecho ya habíamos encontrado
este valor en el vídeo anterior y le
quitamos los impuestos estatales que son
de 1916 y nos da 38 mil 330 dólares como
ingreso neto que nos quedamos así que
nos llevamos a casa 38 mil 330 dólares
después de todos los impuestos esto es
lo que nos llevamos a casa llevamos a
casa
bueno esto podemos averiguar nuestra
tasa efectiva de impuestos
con base en los impuestos federales y
estatales si vemos esto como una
fracción de nuestro suelo original o de
nuestro ingreso original esto entre
50.000
nos queda que es un 76.6 por ciento otra
forma de verlo es aproximadamente un
23.4 o el 23 por ciento de nuestro
ingreso se se usa para pagar impuestos
esta es mi tasa efectiva de impuestos
nuestra tasa
efectiva
de impuestos
qué es el impuesto federal más el
estatal
vemos nuevamente el número y nos
quedamos con el 76.6 por ciento así que
vamos pagando el 23.4 aunque de hecho
creo que es el 23 punto 34 por ciento
así que podemos decir que esto es
aproximadamente el 23 por ciento de
impuestos que se pagan si quieren ver
esto mensualmente con nuestro sueldo
original de 50 mil dólares pues nosotros
pensábamos que nos podríamos llevar a
casa cada mes si esto dividimos entre 12
4 mil 166 dólares mensuales pero ahora
que ya se quitaron todos los impuestos
lo que en realidad vamos a llevarnos
mensualmente es 38.330 entre 12 lo único
que llevaremos a casa mensualmente son 3
mil 194 dólares así que tenemos que
hacer nuestros planes de acuerdo con
esta cantidad